hoje eu vim aqui pra gente desafiar
junto à lógica monogâmica
eu resolvi fazer isso compartilhando um
pouco da minha história com vocês uma
história que envolve sexo envolve
matemática [ __ ] estatística e muito
mistério
é mentira parte do mistério da gente
durante muitos anos e vive em conflito
com essa ideia de que a monogamia é o
único caminho possível para a gente
construir relações saudáveis duradouras
mas principalmente respeitáveis
afinal de contas vocês se lembram do dia
em que resolveram que seriam monogâmicos
pro resto da vida
aquele dia que você acorda queria
rompante assim nossa são monogâmicos que
delícia ou do dia em que seus pais
chamaram pra ter uma conversa séria
sobre as carreiras que você poderia
seguir a partir dali e de repente os
tipos de relacionamento com os quais
iria se deparar ao longo da sua
existência
provavelmente não né eu até lembro de
uma conversa que eu tive com os meus
pais nessa época e no fim das contas eu
acabei do curso de matemática que vocês
podem ver que já também não deu tão
certo assim mas eu tendo seguido o
caminho das exatas eu fui atrás de
tentar racionalizar esse conflito mesmo
que eu tinha com monogamia estudando e
me aprofundando no assunto e por uma
grande ironia do destino acabei ajudando
a desenvolver e hoje tendo acesso ao que
é a maior base de dados do comportamento
sexual do brasileiro
eu sou uma espécie de beijo é do sexo e
não é exagero dizer que eu sei mais da
vida sexual dos outros do que somente
sobre a própria vida
eu sou sócia diretora da maior rede
social the sexes ong do brasil uma
empresa brasileira com um pouco mais de
dez anos de existência e quase oito
milhões de pessoas inscritas
dessas oito milhões de pessoas a maior
parte do público mais engajados são os
casais o que significa que na prática
daria pra gente dobrar o número de
pessoas vivendo ativamente no meio
liberal e algo de muito curioso né não
social que vem crescendo organicamente
em cerca de um milhão um milhão e meio
de pessoas nos últimos anos
a gente estima que hoje existam e
existam no brasil cerca de 40 milhões de
pessoas que já olham para a monogamia
com uma certa desconfiança
a gente deve ter o que eu aqui umas cem
pessoas
eu juro que não vou fazer um cara crachá
que tá mas pela minha estimativa pela
nossa faixa etária também eu posso dizer
sem muito medo de errar que esse assunto
já não é tão novidade assim pelo menos
metade das pessoas aqui e foi fuçando e
estudando esse assunto tendo essa base
de dados de comportamento disponível que
eu confirmei que de fato a monogamia
está longe de ser uma unanimidade hoje a
popularidade dela está muito restrito ao
discurso embasado em tabu e moralismo e
não necessariamente embasado na
realidade ea verdade é que existe uma
diferença grande entre o que dizem que a
gente deveria viver e sentir o que de
fato a gente vive sente e muitas vezes a
distância entre uma coisa e outra é
fruto de muito muito sofrimento e que se
a gente parar pra pensar
ele é absolutamente desnecessário eu
converso diariamente com casais que me
contam com sufocados eles se sentiam até
que eles percebessem que era possível
propor algo de diferente para aquelas
relações e são esses casais também que
admitem como eles jogavam outras pessoas
que viviam uma sexualidade diferente do
que a gente chama de padrão porque eles
achavam que isso era coisa de gente
irresponsável imatura e completamente
safadão eu até não ser no lego uma certa
dose de safadeza sakineh quem nunca
massa é pois é preciso lembrar que há
milhares de motivos que podem levar um
casal a testar algo diferente na sua
relação de um casal que quando conheci
recentemente ele tem uma história muito
fantástica
ela teve câncer de mama e isso afetou
muito a autoestima dela a imagem que ela
tinha
mesmo de si mesmo como mulher e foi um
processo muito doloroso que parecia não
ter volta
mas o casal depois curado eles
conversaram e combinaram de tirar foto
um do outro principalmente para que ela
entendesse um pouco que olhar era esse
que o marido ainda tinha sobre o corpo
dela um olhar de desejo que tava tão
distante da da imagem dela sobre si
mesmo
eles tiraram as fotos gostaram e fora
vamos publicar não compartilha e nem
eram super luta está a gente é um semi
nu diz assim e eles compartilharam
algumas dessas fotos e esses m nudes e
algumas legendas colocou algumas
legendas
o a comunidade entendeu que estava
passando ali com aquele casal e o
feedback foi fantástico
foram muitas curtidas muitas mensagens
xavecos e aquilo mudou completamente a
imagem que ela tinha sobre si mesmo
naquele momento e ela comenta que ela
comentou comigo que não é que tudo mudou
do dia pra noite porque esse é um
processo lento e que precisa mesmo de de
força e tempo para acontecer
mas ela enxergou ali naquele momento a
primeira possibilidade de voltar a se
amar e de quem sabe renascer até como
uma exibicionista e essa é a mágica da
conexão porque se por um lado a internet
carrega essa culpa de ter democratizado
uma fotografia que é altamente misógina
corrosiva violenta e isso tem impactos
profundos na nossa sexualidade por outro
ela que permitiu e ainda permite que com
uma boa dose de anonimato a gente
descubra que há milhares de pessoas ao
nosso redor que gostam das mesmas coisas
que a gente praticamente não há espaço
pra solidão se você gosta de pés por
exemplo
esse é um fetiche super com a verdade é
também esse é um fetiche muito comum
existem até redes sociais inteiras
dedicadas a isso
se você gosta de roupas de látex ou você
gosta de observar esse é observado
basta uma busca rápida para você
encontrar lugares onde as pessoas
compartilham esse tipo de conteúdo curta
em conversa e principalmente acolhem
outras
os que têm esses interesses em comum e é
muito legal também olhar para esses
dados de comportamento de uma forma
macro o piauí por exemplo hoje é a
região do brasil onde tem o maior
percentual de pessoas que se declaram
abertamente como sadomasoquista
já no paraná eu tenho o maior percentual
de pessoas que diz que beijar na boca
durante uma relação sexual
talvez não seja tão fundamental assim
nessas redes sociais as pessoas mais
velhas acabam fazendo mais sucesso por
uma questão de proteção segurança
competente confidencialidade e o termo
utilizado para procurá-las é o coroa e
esse é um dos termos está no top five de
termos mais buscados principalmente em
são paulo e no ceará
apesar de toda a pressão social e
engordou fobia que principalmente as
mulheres sofrem nessas redes sociais as
mulheres gordas tem muito orgulho de
utilizar o termo bw para se identificar
bill e fumam e esse é um dos termos mais
digitados em vários estados
principalmente no rio de janeiro já
homenagem masculino que a relação entre
dois homens e uma mulher é a apresentou
o apresenta mais buscas em 60% do que
homenagear feminino que a relação entre
duas mulheres e um homem em um
escritório que eu gosto muito e ele tem
um texto maravilhoso que chama
autoestima na [ __ ] o nome dele alex
castro e esse foi um texto escrito antes
da democratização dos lucros antes da
gente ter celular essas coisas assim mas
ele basicamente comenta com luciana você
não participa de uma [ __ ] é possível
que você passa a vida inteira sem ver
uma pessoa foi atrasado
porque quando a nossa referência de sexo
é construída por filme novela a
pornografia editoriais revistas
a mensagem que você recebe é que só tem
gente é super magra linda depilada que
não transpira com paus enormes trocando
por aí
nesses canais de entretenimento tudo o
que foge desse padrão só serve copiada e
aí que mora o grande valor da [ __ ] que
hoje inclusive você pode participar
virtualmente
quando você começa a verter a festa
pessoas gente como a gente transando que
tem celulite estria gente alta gorda
magra baixa com dificuldade de locomoção
gozando e fazendo gozar a mensagem que
você recebe de que essas pessoas podem
eu posso também e quem mais se beneficia
disso não são os jovens que mais leves
assuntos a sério e que encara isso como
estilo de vida são os casais maduros com
os filhos já criados que já tiveram
outras relações monogâmicas ou até mesmo
já viveram única monogâmica mente essas
relações mas em algum momento viram uma
brecha pra testar alguma coisa nova
uma prova disso é que os nossos picos de
acesso eles acontecem sempre às
segundas-feiras volta de feriado retorno
de férias escolares porque casais como
outros quaisquer que dedicam a semana o
trabalho os finais de semana os filhos a
nas férias escolares reúnem às famílias
mas é gente como a gente também que
depois de vários dias juntos tudo o que
eles precisam é de uma boa válvula de
escape da rotina e por que não uma rede
social de sexo e juntos como um casal e
foi estudando e analisando esses
comportamentos e conversando muito com
essa culpa principalmente esses casais
maduros que eu cheguei aos três
principais motivos que têm levado cada
vez mais pessoas a se aventurarem pelo
universo liberal em primeiro lugar
a essa primeira vez na história em que a
gente continua procurando casa é casar
casamento em relações duradouras
mas não
é procriar como se não houvesse amanhã
nesse momento a gente procura parceiros
quilos de insegurança proteção um senso
de permanência e previsibilidade sejam
que sejam parceiros que desafio desafio
intelectual mente que nos bem o senso de
aventura e também mantenha a chama do
desejo da paixão acesos mesmo depois de
dez vinte ou trinta anos de
relacionamento e isso pode ser demais
para uma pessoa só e reconhecer isso
pode ser muito libertador libertador pra
nós que projetamos as expectativas em um
parceiro só libertador para nós também
como quando somos alvos dessas
expectativas
e quando assumimos uma certa
vulnerabilidade de que olha talvez não
seja capaz de te dá tudo isso sozinho
é quando a gente percebe isso e também
quando a gente ganha consciência de que
nosso parceiro ou parceira
são seres únicos e completos em si
mesmos capazes de ter prazer e dar
prazer
de repente alguém que não é você porque
afinal de contas ela nasceu grudado em
você ou não depende de você ela pode ser
gente do próprio prazer o prazer do
outro que às vezes pode não ser você
é nesse momento que muitos casais
conseguem fugir da lógica da posse do
ciúme e transformá la numa lógica de
tesão e excitação em segundo lugar no
mundo onde a privacidade vem ganhando
cada vez mais novos contornos muitos
casais têm descoberto a força eo alívio
que é trocar lógica das relações
monogâmicas muitas vezes pautados por
mentiras e traições teológica das
relações pautadas pelo diálogo onde
prevalece o respeito pelos seus
sentimentos e os sentimentos dos outros
afinal de contas hoje é difícil falar em
dados ao nosso respeito que não estou no
google no facebook
assim como é difícil eu sair de casa e
até a padaria não ser seguida por um
monte de câmeras de segurança
então me parece um pouco otimista pensar
que a gente vai continuar fazendo tudo
100% na surdina me parece um bom momento
também para cuidar da relação com quem
você deseja passar o resto da vida de um
casal muito legal com que é um converso
sempre e eles me contam que
até alguns anos atrás eles nunca tinham
conversado sobre nada disso do que a
gente está falando
até que um dia a esposa descobriu que o
marido passava as noites em claro
assistindo o site life khan esse onde as
mulheres casais exibem tirou a roupa e
ela ficou muito bravo porque aquilo não
estava no combinado mesmo daquela
daquela relação monogâmica
mas ela é muito maravilhosa ela reagiu
do jeito mais maravilhoso possível a
você está se divertindo aí então essa
noite eu preciso de privacidade porque
quem vai se exibir sou eu e hoje anos
depois eles têm um perfil juntos e eles
são praticamente embaixadores nesse
estilo de vida explicando para as
pessoas como funciona aquela como
funcionam as possíveis relações abertas
e liberais e criando conexões que vão
muito além do sexo em terceiro lugar
eu destaco com muita felicidade que há
um movimento de descoberta do corpo real
principalmente do corpo feminino que
passou tantos anos sendo castrado tendo
a sua sexo sexualidade anulado
essa pode parecer uma realidade long um
pouco longe pra muitas de nós mas ainda
é uma realidade para muitas mulheres que
ainda não descobriram que podem ser
agentes do próprio desejo e do desejo do
outro também ter eu tenho um casal muito
legal com quem eu converso
principalmente nos nossos eventos
eu sou super fã deles porque eu acho que
ele tem a cara dessa relação é dessa
geração um pouco mais velha que aceitou
as novidades com muita coragem sabe e
ela me conta que nunca tinha comprado
uma lingerie antes dos 40
simplesmente porque ela nunca tinha
parado para pensar nisso ela achava que
não era pra ela tinha mais com que se
preocupar
até o dia em que ela descobriu que
existia todo esse universo de mulheres
parecidas com elas exibido por aí
mulheres com o corpo parecido com a
história parecida com a família
aparecida e aquilo fez ou a rever vários
aspectos da vida e foi depois dos 40 que
ela comprou a primeira lingerie
assim como foi depois dos 40 que ela
percebeu que tinha passado a vida
inteira jogando outras mulheres que
tinham uma sexualidade um pouco mais
livre porque elas usavam realizar coisas
que ela não era boa
que é pra imaginar
e por que tudo isso é importante porque
a gente já vive castelo demais e
padronizado demais e eu não estou aqui
pra questionar se a monogamia é natural
ou não ou se a não monogamia é o ideal
para todo mundo porque nisso eu também
não acredito mas o que eu não acredito
mesmo é que uma regra seja capaz de
acolher todos os indivíduos e nesse
sentido é importante lembrar que há
pessoas que vão passar a existência
inteira vivendo monogâmica mente
plenamente
tem pessoas que vão passar a existência
vivendo não monogâmica mente tem gente
que sequer deseja um relacionamento
amoroso ou sexual
o importante é que a gente tome decisões
mais lúcidos mas sem julgamento em torno
de como a gente quer se relacionar com
outras pessoas querem se relacionar ao
olhar com carinho os nossos desejos
permite que a gente olhe com carinho
desejo dos outros também entender que há
coisas que eu gosto e que não são uma
unanimidade e que está tudo bem
assim como há coisas que os outros
desejam que não me dizem nada e que está
tudo bem também mas vocês sabem que
nessa minha busca por respostas a
respeito do tipo de tipos diferentes de
relacionamentos
o mais engraçado nesses meus 35 anos de
vida é difícil dizer com que o trabalho
né
muitas vezes eu explica o passo aqui
fazê-lo pede para a pessoa no meio do
bar e aí depois ela me olha 5 aquele ar
de espanto falar que é legal você
trabalha com pornografia neste momento
em que o choro por dentro né
mas tá tudo bem a verdade é que ainda é
difícil mesmo resumir o que eu faço que
o trabalho mas eu descobri que nesse meu
interesse pela pornografia meu interesse
maior é por fazer conexões conectar
pessoas e permitir que elas percebam que
elas não estão sozinhas porque a não
violência com os nossos sentimentos é um
passo fundamental para a não-violência
consentimento dos outros
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]